DANGEROUS FOR THE MANY PEOPLE
THAT LIVE IN THIS AREA C AREA.
>> THANK YOU VERY MUCH I WANT TO
GET BACK TO OUR BREAKING NEWS, A
MAJOR UPDATE IN THE LAST MINUTE
FROM THE FAA.
THEY'RE ORDERING ALL AIRLINES,
ALL DOMESTIC U.S. AIRLINES TO
PAUSE DEPARTURES UNTIL 9:00 A.M.
EASTERN TIME.
THE FAA WORKING TO FULLY RESTORE
THE NOTICE TO AIR MISSION SYSTEM
FOLLOWING THE OUTAGE.
THE FAA NOTICED AIRLINES TO
PAUSE ALL DEPARTURES TO 9:00
A.M. EASTERN TIME TO ALLOW THE
AGENCY TO VALIDATE THE AND WE
-- THE INTEGRITY OF FLIGHT
INFORMATION.
>> PETER GOELZ IS CNN'S AVIATION
MANAGER AND FORMER DIRECTOR OF
THE NTSB.
YOU HEARD THE NEWS THAT POPPY
JUST READ.
FAA ANNOUNCING IT'S ORDERING ALL
DEPARTURES ONHOLD TO VALIDATE
THE INTEGRITY OF FLIGHT SAFETY
INFORMATION.
WHAT SAY YOU?
>> IT'S EXTRAORDINARY.
IT UNDERSCORES WHAT SOME OF THE
OTHERS HAVE MENTIONED THIS
MORNING.
THE FRAGIITY OF THE SYSTEM.
IF THIS GOES DOWN, THE WHOLE
SYSTEM COMES TO A HALT AND IT
CASCADES THROUGHOUT THE DAY.
PILOTS HAVE TO HAVE THIS
INFORMATION.
THEY NEED TO KNOW WHETHER THE
APPROACH PATTERNS THAT THEY'RE
USING ARE FULLY FUNCTIONAL.
THEY NEED TO KNOW WHAT'S GOING
ON AT INDIVIDUAL AIRPORTS
WHETHER TAXI WAYS ARE CLOSED,
RUNWAYS ARE CLOSED.
THIS IS ESSENTIAL FLIGHT
INFORMATION THAT EVERY PILOT HAS
TO RECEIVE AND CHECK BEFORE THEY
GO ON A MISSION AND FLY
PASSENGERS.
THIS IS A PRETTY BIG DEAL.
>> A HUGE DEAL.
I WANT TO BE CLEAR FOR OUR
VIEWERS, PETE, DOMESTIC
DEPARTURES.
WITH YOUR EXPERIENCE, WOULD THIS
IMPACT LANDINGS AT ALL?
OF COURSE IT DOES BECAUSE
SOMETIMES THE NOTIFICATIONS ARE
DIRECTED TOWARDS THE APPROACH
PATTERNS.
EVERY AIRPORT HAS MULTIPLE
APPROACH PATTERNS FROM THE NORTH
AND THE SOUTH AND ON OCCASION,
SOME OF THESE APPROACH PATTERNS
HAVE MORE PRECISE LANDING
NAVIGATIONAL EQUIPMENT.
IF SOME OF THAT EQUIPMENT IS NOT
FUNCTIONING OR IS OFF LINE FOR
MAINTENANCE, PILOTS NEED TO KNOW
THAT SO THEY'RE NOT COMING --
USING THOSE APPROACHES DURING
HEAVY WEATHER.
SO IT REALLY IS ESSENTIAL
INFORMATION.
>> FORGIVE ME FOR INTERRUPTING,
PETER.
BUT YOU HAVE TO GET THESE PLANES
DOWN AT SOME POINT.
YOU HAVE A LOT OF RED EYES THAT
WOULD BE COMING FROM THE WEST
COAST TO THE EAST COAST.
WE KNOW EUROPE HAS NOT CLOSED
DOWN THEIR MAJOR TAKEOFFS AND
MANY OF THOSE FLIGHTS ARE COMING
TO THE U.S.
SO WHAT DO YOU DO?
>> WELL, PLANES IN THE AIR ARE
GOING TO HAVE TO BE IN CLOSE
COMMUNICATIONS WITH THEIR AIR
TRAFFIC CONTROLLERS.
IT'S GOING TO PUT -- YOU KNOW,
THE AIR TRAFFIC CONTROLLERS ARE
GOING TO BE ASKED TO TAKE ON,
YOU KNOW, A GREATER
INFORMATIONAL ROLE.
THEY'RE GOING TO HAVE TO PASS ON
THE INFORMATION ABOUT OUTAGES
AND SPECIAL CONDITIONS AT THE
AIRPORTS THAT THEY'RE
CONTROLLING TO THE PILOTS.
THEY NEED TO REITERATE IF THERE
ARE ANY OUTAGES DIRECTLY TO THE
FLIGHT CREWS AS THEY'RE COMING
IN P.
>> BUT PETER.
>> OR THE PLANES WILL HAVE TO BE
DIVERTED TO AIRPORTS WHERE
VISUAL FLIGHT RULES ARE IN
EFFECT.
>> SO THE QUESTION IS, THOUGH,
IS THERE SOME SORT OF DRILL?
THERE HAS TO BE PROTOCOL FOR
THIS IN CASE SOMETHING LIKE THIS
HAPPENS THIS IS WHAT WE DO.
IT'S NOT LIKE PLANES ARE WILLY
NILLY FLYING ABOUT WITHOUT BEING
ABLE TO COMMUNICATE WITH EACH
OTHER.
THERE'S A SYSTEM IN PLACE, ONE
WOULD HOPE, IN CASE THE SYSTEM
WENT OUT, THE THING THAT GUIDES
A PILOT, A NORMAL SYSTEM, THEY'D
BE ABLE TO GET THE PLANES IN THE
SKY TO LAND THEM SAFELY.
>> OF COURSE.
AS I SAY, IT PUTS GREATER
RESPONSIBILITY ON THE AIR
TRAFFIC CONTROLLERS, ON THE
FLIGHT CREWS TO COMMUNICATE WITH
THE AIR TRAFFIC CONTROLLERS.
BUT THERE ARE SYSTEMS IN PLACE,
NO ONE IS GOING TO BE LEFT
CIRCLING.
>> YEAH.
OKAY, PETER STAND BY.
AGAIN, THE BREAKING NEWS,
DEPARTURES UNTIL THE FAA IS
PAUSING ALL U.S. DEPARTURES
UNTIL 9:00 A.M. BECAUSE OF THIS
SYSTEM OUTAGE.
>> A HUGE DEAL.
>> A BIG DEAL.
THIS IS WHY WE STOPPED REPORTING
EVERYTHING ELSE.
BUT YOU KNOW, YOU COVER BUSINESS
AND SO DOES CHRISTINE ROMANS.
LET'S BRING HER IN NOW.
YOU MENTIONED, POPPY, YOU SAID
THAT THIS IS BUSINESS TRAVEL,
THE PEOPLE USUALLY START NOW
WITH BUSINESS TRAVEL.
WHAT DOES IT MEAN?
>> IT'S A TOUGH TIME FOR THIS TO
BE HAPPENING.
FOR THE PROBLEMS WE HAD,
REMEMBER OVER THE HOLIDAYS,
SOUTHWEST AIRLINES THAT WAS A
BAD TIME FOR THEM AS WELL TRYING
TO RESOLVE THE PROBLEMS WITH
BAGGAGE AND GET PEOPLE REUNITED
WITH THE BAGGAGE, THE HIGH
MARGIN PART OF THE TRAVEL IS THE
BUSINESS TRAVEL.
THIS IS AN IMPORTANT PART FOR
AIRLINES' BOTTOM LINES.
THINK OF THE LOST PRODUCTIVITY
OF PEOPLE WAITING AT AN AIRPORT
WAITING TO FIGURE OUT IF THEY'RE
REMAKING THEIR CONNECTION.
IT COMES AT A TOUGH TIME OVERALL
FOR AN AIRLINE INDUSTRY TRYING
TO COME ON THE OF THE COVID ERA
AND GRAPPLE WITH HUGE DEMAND FOR
TRAVEL AND LEISURE AND BUSINESS
TRAVEL.
>> DO WE HAVE AN UPDATE NOW?
>> HOW MANY?
DO WE KNOW?
>> OVER 1,200 FOR NOW.
>> BUT IF THEY'RE DELAYING THEM
ALL, IT'S MORE.
>> ROMANS I WAS THINKING OF THE
NEW LAW THAT CAME INTO EFFECT A
FEW YEARS AGO THAT PASSENGERS
CAN GET A LOT OF MONEY BACK FROM
THE AIRLINESES IF THEY SIT ON
THE TARMAC FOR THREE OUR SIX
HOURS.
>> THIS IS SOMETHING THAT WAS A
PROBLEM WITH THE FAA.
THIS DOESN'T SEEM TO BE AN
AIRLINE PROBLEM THIS IS A
PROBLEM SYSTEM WIDE.
BUT YOU'RE RIGHT, THIS WAS
MODELLED AFTER GENEROUS LAWS IN
EUROPE.
IF YOU, AT THE FAULT OF AN
AIRLINE ARE SITTING ON THE
TARMAC OR THE AIRPORT FOR A
COUPLE HOURS IN EUROPE, YOU GET
BIG MONEY BACK AND THAT WAS
SOMETHING THAT TRAVEL ADVOCATES,
CONSUMER ADVOCATES IN THE U.S.
WANTED TO MODEL BECAUSE SO MANY
PEOPLE WERE SPENDING SO MUCH
TIME, FELT LIKE THEY WERE AT THE
WHIM OF AIRLINES.
>> THIS NOT THE AIRLINES' FAULT.
>> DOESN'T APPEAR TO BE.
>> THE BREAKING NEWS HERE ON
CNN, THE FAA HAS A SYSTEM
OUTAGE, HOLDING ALL DEPARTING
FLIGHTS UNTIL AT LEAST 9:00 A.M.
WE KNOW THERE ARE 1200, PROBABLY
MORE FLIGHTING THAT HAVE BEEN
DELAYED AND STOPPED FROM TAKING
OFF HERE IN THE UNITED STATES.
ALSO, UNITED AIRLINES IS SAYING
OBVIOUSLY THEY HAVE STOPPED ALL
FLIGHTS BECAUSE EVERYTHING
STOPPED, T